um your report talks a very near misses
were we lucky that nobody died
uh sadly that's the conclusion that i
have reached that essentially it was an
incredibly near miss
we were probably seconds or minutes away
from either a life-changing injury or
indeed worse of fatality
the stadium that's behind me
breaches were attempted 17 times they
were mass breaches both trying to get
into disabled bays where they
essentially pushed people in wheelchairs
out the way or followed them in
doors closed and they pushed up against
that gets you crushed
i people human beings being crushed
and the other
one that we're very clear about is they
tried to force the fire doors and the
safety tools from the outside and by so
doing then you have this surge of people
in and again we have clear evidence of
people falling
two or three people falling on each
other sam you know yourself that in a
sports situation is so incredibly
dangerous and the safety situation is so
incredibly dangerous we had children
here on that day we had you know
grandparents here on that day i've seen
cctv that's made my stair and my hair
stand on end and we were very very close
to a major a major disaster yeah i was
there myself with my little 10 year old
fella and it was frightening certainly
on on the way in and then also on the
way out your report does reference that
it was a perfect storm we've got the
backdrop of the pandemic and lockdown
effects on people the first football
final
for decades but those mitigating
circumstances aside
you found unequivocally that planning at
wembley was not good enough and all
agencies were caught off guard
yes i'm afraid that's the case i think
clearly what happened is uh covid
was a
really important factor in some ways i
think it was a distraction
and it meant that for example there was
no major fan zone in london
uh because of the covid regulations they
they couldn't have a fan zone which i
think was a huge issue i think the
metropolitan police would argue that
they had nowhere to disperse people to
the stadium of course was not full
that's a highly unusual situation so
people coming here thought they might
chance it and certainly having spent a
day drinking and using drugs their
entitlement to chancing it was greater
than probably it would have been if
they'd been sober
you also have the fact that here in
wembley a lot of the pubs were on
restricted numbers so normally there's
about 9000 people can drink in the pubs
around here they have 1 500 on the day
so there were mitigating factors but the
problem was sam
nobody put all of that together and
switched the light on that said ah when
england are playing in a final when
we've got national euphoria where we've
got covid all of the factors that were
the perfect storm were also the factors
that i think people
could have foreseen and that's why i'm
saying uh this wasn't a government
review but i am asking the government
respectfully uh that it should be
something that we should consider as a
country about a a game of national
significance
now the other
i was just going to say i mean you said
nobody sort of had that light bulb
moment and said this is going to be a
problem uh baroness louise
who should that have been should it have
been should have been the fa should it
have been the police
well we have in this country we have a
very
we have something called a safety
advisory group that is part of the
system to check safety
and they together
frankly missed the size of this they did
make changes along the way
but i think to be fair to them
i don't think any of them could have
predicted the
huge outpouring of violence and criminal
behavior nothing in the plans nothing in
our system as it stands at the moment
you know stadiums aren't built
and policing isn't created to actually
try and contain
mass violent disorder of what we saw on
that sunday so yeah i'm really clear
there was a perfect storm i am really
clear that mistakes were made i don't i
don't call negligence very clear on the
distinction between those two and
secondly if anything comes out of this
the most important thing that comes out
of this is that we take a long hard look
at ourselves and eradicate this type of
criminal behavior from football football
is used as a vehicle for thuggery and
for racism and i think if there's one
thing i'd like to see change over the
fact that we didn't have a disaster on
that sunday we had a near miss it would
be rooting out once and for all this
thuggish behavior which seems to be
what football gives them yeah and that's
a disgrace and it's humiliating nobody's
seeking to exculpate the behavior of
some of those the people that were there
you want to create a set of protocols
around events of national significance
that's what you want to come out of this
who would be at the top of that chain of
command because the problem seems to be
and your answer to my question about
who's to blame is that nobody really
holds the pen do they here
so i think that's a really i think
that's one of the things i'm really
clear about is that one of the
recommendations in the review
is that the safety group advisory
organization is recharged with the
responsibility to review
who is responsible for what we call
zonex so there's a there's a
on wembley way or olympic ways it's now
called from those steps behind me down
to the tube station is called zonex who
is responsible for community and public
safety on zonex is just not clear enough
and i think that's where the fourth
recommendation about charging them
because they are the safety specialists
in brokering that deal i want a red dot
on someone's head when we have an event
of national significance that everybody
knows who takes who takes responsibility
and this this isn't left to
a group of people it's left to a system
that determines it and one of the checks
we would have if they will think about
doing this is that as part of the
process built into that process is an
independent look an independent
checkpoint that is automatically part of
it because what happened here is it's
like like a load of people have got head
torches on right so they're looking
through the the lens through their own
head torch and nobody stuck the lights
on and said what is happening in the
room and if we had an event of national
significance particularly for a football
like this football match like this it
will be built into the system that
somebody comes along and switches that
light on and i think that would have
been something incredibly helpful on
that day but i don't want to
underestimate that the near miss the
loss of life was about the recklessness
the chosen recklessness of people that
decided to try and break into the
stadium and they need to have that on
their heads
that's the shame yeah a lot of the wider
questions about the culture of football
supporters baroness casey you are
somebody if you don't mind me saying who
is known for a no-nonsense approach and
for getting things done how much
confidence have you got that this won't
just be another report another review
that's gathering dust on a shelf
somewhere
well
in these scenarios and then one that as
serious as this i am never confident
until i see the action that flows
there's no point people like me writing
reports unless there's change so i'm not
confident of anyone at the moment i
believe that they will do the right
thing and that they will make changes
the police the fa safety people brent
either you know no one wants this to
happen again and indeed the government
but until i see change i won't be
confident